[Musique]
le nouveau propriétaire de Twitter iron
musk a envoyé un courriel très direct à
ses employés la nuit dernière il leur
demande de s'engager à travailler de
longues heures à forte intensité ou de
partir les employés jusqu'à demain soir
pour répondre ceux qui partent au Rond
droit à 3 mois de salaire et une masque
a déclaré qu'il avait l'intention de
réduire le temps qu'il passe chez
Twitter et qu'il allait éventuellement
trouver quelqu'un pour diriger
l'entreprise
le Québécois Patrick Pichette était
membre du conseil d'administration qui a
prouvé la vente de Twitter à Elon Musk
Patrick Pichette et de passage au Québec
dans le but de faire une annonce sur la
conservation de la réserve konok en
Outaouais nous l'avons rencontré en
milieu d'après-midi
Patrick Pichat bonjour bonjour c'est le
plaisir de vous accueillir vous arrivez
de monter Bello parce que vous avez un
immense projet qui s'appelle konok
n'est-ce pas en plein développement on
va en parler dans un instant mais avant
ça je vous parle de Twitter parce que
vous étiez membre du conseil de
administration de Twitter vous êtes
étonné que je vous parle de ça il me
demande ce qui est arrivé et a acheté
l'entreprise et à licencier l'ensemble
du conseil d'administration est-ce que
tout s'est passé dans l'ordre il y a eu
tellement de volts face tellement
d'épisodes comment vous avez vécu ce qui
s'est passé dans les dernières semaines
jusqu'au moment où il l'a acheté puis
qui ont la closé la transaction début
novembre début novembre tous dépassé
comme le Conseil espérer
depuis ce temps-là c'est sa compagnie
alors il va falloir l'appeler lui pour
lui demander pourquoi c'est quoi c'est
de jouer à deux jours un jour puis
d'heure mais pour nous au Conseil puis
moi je faisais partie du comité de
transaction depuis le tout début parce
que c'était moi qui était sur le comité
de vérification de la compagnie alors
on avait on avait les objectifs très
clairs puis on les a accomplis
donc vous vouliez vendre et vous êtes
heureux d'avoir vendu à 54 dollars 20
l'action vous avez quelques actions de
Twitter à 44 milliards c'était la
meilleure transaction pour vous et dans
l'intérêt aussi
de la société parce que je veux vous
donner je vais il y a une nuance à faire
ici justement très important si Twitter
avait une compagnie canadienne on a dit
on a un cadre de gouvernance au Canada à
cause de la décision de Berkane dans les
années
2008 au Canada le conseil
d'administration a une obligation
fiduciaire envers la compagnie
puisse pencher sur les intérêts de tous
les de toutes les parties
les parties prenantes aux États-Unis
c'est pas la même chose aux États-Unis
tu vois quand on a commencé le débat on
s'est fait on s'est fait très rappeler
par nos avocats
puis quand tu comprends ça à ce
moment-là ta seule obligation
c'est de maximiser la valeur aux
actionnaires et c'est ce que vous avez
fait à 54 dollars 54$ 20 40 milliards
un milliard c'est 1000 millions
il y en a quelques-uns dans vos poches
parce que vous êtes actionnaires vous
êtes actionnaires
j'ai quelques actions puis s'en vont
tous à mon projet Canac et ah oui dans
votre projet dont on va parler dans
quelques instants mais je reste sur
Twitter est-ce que c'est dans l'intérêt
de la société qui est le masque soit
propriétaire de Twitter
je pense que si on avait été au Canada
si ça avait été une société canadienne
on a eu un débat beaucoup plus important
pourquoi parce que justement
Twitter c'est une plateforme
c'est le
square
puis c'est
l'endroit public où les gens ou les
groupes marginalisés ou les gens qui ont
besoin de protection peuvent s'exprimer
librement c'est une plateforme
absolument extraordinaire importante
c'est pour ça que j'étais au conseil
c'est une société de conséquence mais
vous avez pris des décisions notamment
le jour où on décide que Donald Trump
par exemple n'est plus sur la plateforme
de Twitter parce qu'il y a eu le 6
janvier 2021 les appels à la haine ça ça
compte pas quand vous prenez la décision
de vendre à Elon Musk qui dit ben moi
j'ai pas d'accord avec les modalités de
liberté d'expression décider chez
Twitter à deux points là le premier
c'est la décision de
chez Twitter
durant le temps que moi j'étais à la
société on avait les règles de Twitter
qui sont relativement simple n'importe
qui peut aller sur le site puis lire de
Twitter
il y a une réelle qui dit tu as pas le
droit d'insister à la violence le fait
que
en ce moment et qui on voit une réponse
de citoyens puis j'ai une réponse de
conseil d'administration mes obligations
en tant que chef du Conseil
c'était
de respecter mes obligations fiduciaires
pour un corpus
parce que ça me tente alors est-ce que
vous restez sur Twitter si moi je suis
sur Twitter bien sûr avoir ce matin
j'avais une belle photo de neige donc ça
ne vous inquiète pas comme citoyen qui
est le masque soit le propriétaire de
toiture
je te dirais que c'est quoi ces dingue
qui avait dit la fameuse phrase tout
terrain trop tôt pour le dire le temps
va bien faire les choses puis je veux
rester optimiste dans le sens où d'abord
il y a d'autres plateformes puis on les
voit qui prennent forme
si il a une brise les toasts de Twitter
la beauté de l'internet c'est demain
matin à 8 au plafond qui se pointe puis
ça j'ai beaucoup confiance en ça puis en
fait c'est ça qui est le plus important
c'est que une société ouverte avec des
moyens ouverts pour trouver le bon
canard vous annoncez puisque vous êtes
optimiste vous le dites la création
d'une forme de laboratoire de recherche
avec conservation de la nature Canada
sur les changements climatiques dans la
réserve de konok Knokke
c'est pas facile à dire en Outaouais
dont vous êtes le copropriétaire vous
voulez faire quoi de cette immense
territoire absolument exceptionnel
il y a des investissements que tu fais
avec ta tête tu as des investissements
que tu fais avec ton cœur
que cette définitivement
c'est un territoire qui a été le seul
lui tout seul depuis toujours ça a été
la seigneurie de Louis Joseph Papineau
la Great canadienne peut se faire cuire
on avait fait essentiellement un club
privé pour dans l'ancien temps le monde
avait des clubs privés
ils ont rien fait avec ils sont assurés
que ils n'ont pas développé puis avec le
déboulement de l'histoire ça fait en
sorte que il était caché dans un bar une
fille d'un fond de pension puis
quelqu'un a décidé d'essayer de le
développer puis quand j'ai appris ça
puis moi j'avais un chalet faire des de
l'immobilier de l'immobilier sur le
territoire puis ça c'est un territoire
qui est tellement grand que deux meubles
de nous il est tellement grand
la première année qu'on a commencé à
faire l'inventaire biologique nos petits
étudiants qui étaient là et on finit
l'été et puis on trouvait des insectes
puis les professeurs d'université
pouvaient pas ils sont ramasser à
l'éthologie de ta voix pour apprendre
que tu as des nouvelles espèces qu'on
avait jamais entendu parler donc là vous
le protégez vous lancez une campagne de
financement pour terminer le financement
de la protection à 100% du territoire
exactement ce qu'on fait c'est on donne
les clés
à un institut qui est un objet
Abu non lucratif
va devenir essentiellement le gardien de
kanak puis il fait en partenariat avec
conservation de la nature
puisqu'on fait avec conservation de la
nature c'est
on donne la conservation de la nature
tous les terrains de grande valeur sur
Canac comme ça jamais les prochaines
générations vont être tentées de
monétiser donc on enlève toute la valeur
du terrain comme ça il y a plus d'argent
à faire bon à faire
de ce côté là parce que ça c'est un
cadeau pour les universités pour
l'éducation pour amener les gens de la
maternelle à l'université pour explorer
le terrain là tu peux faire de la
recherche sur 50 ans ou 100 ans puis on
crée le plus gros laboratoire de efforts
et de recherche en Amérique du Nord
Patrick puchette merci c'est un plaisir
de vous accueillir merci d'avoir été
avec nous toujours un plaisir de vous
voir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI